hello there and welcome to Playstation
grenade Marvel spider-man is shaping up
to battle God of War for the title of
greatest first party game of the year on
September the 7th Spidey will be
unleashed upon the world and a hype
machine is now in full motion recently a
press event gave us access to 2 hours of
the game and here's 15 details we've had
confirmed about spider-man on ps4 from
the moment you switch on your ps4 and
load up Marvel spider-man you'll know
the game has been created with love and
respect for spider-man's history
something as subtle as choosing your
difficulty level of easy normal or heart
is given a nod to the Spidey verse with
friendly replacing easy amazing trading
places with normal and spectacular
swapping the top spot for hardest
difficulty I know it's not my blood but
it's salute spider-man's comic-book
history and other references are strewn
across the entire story and open-world
so keep a lookout for more obscure
references and we'll put together an
easter egg video later
What's Wrong Willie you seem angry I
will destroy you the story itself
follows spider-man like you'd expect but
it's just as much about Peter Parker as
his alter-ego Peter Parker how the hell
are you here's the twist in this unique
timeline Peter isn't a photojournalist
for the Daily Bugle he's a scientist
well a budding scientist anyway he's
still relatively young and only just
making his own steps into the world as
an adult
he's been spider-man for years now so we
don't have to put up with another origin
story in the game we'll take control of
Peter at work in sort of minigame esque
scientist Charles completing lab tests
but more importantly the work he does
here impacts the suits and the gadgets
he uses when wearing spandex and
swooping across the open world
peter is joined by a few familiar faces
such as Aunt May MJ and Miles Morales
and now's a great time to reiterate this
is a whole new universe for the webhead
not only has Peter's occupation being
slightly realigned so has Mary James we
won't find her on Broadway or even
running a night club in this world NJ is
the up-and-coming journalist looking for
a huge story to break think of her in
the same way you would Lois Lane in
Superman or April O'Neill in the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles MJ will get her
story any way she can and that's why we
will be playing as Mary Jane during the
game she'll have her own objectives her
own gameplay style her own mechanics
from what we've seen so far MJ is like a
stealthy sleuth looking for clues to
uncover it's kind of like Batman's
detective skill crossed with heavy rain
searching for items and Intel it's a far
cry from being spider-man but adds an
anxious nervousness to proceedings which
should break up the story well can I
call you I mean you had a cell phone in
your in your pockets or something even
Miles Morales is here in the same
universe as Peter but it isn't due to
time travel or hopping from one
dimension to another or a random video
game crossover in this game he's legit
he was born and raised in New York
there's no smoke and mirrors here so
we'll get to see how those two
characters would work together even
though this is a brand-spanking-new
timeline and story there will be a
truckload of nods to previous Spiderman
adventures from other Spider versus and
other shenanigans Peter got up too
during his high school spider-man days
an example of this is inside one of the
backpacks scattered around New York if
you find one of Peters old high school
rucksacks inside one of them will be a
vial of sand in reference to the time he
defeated the Sandman another nod comes
in the shape of a blueprint found early
on in the game called Devil's breath
which is in reference to miss the
negatives first appearance in the comic
books in which he attempted to kill off
all his opposition by using a bio weapon
and you guessed it it was called Devil's
breath welcome to the park Justin
without fireworks speaking of enemies so
far we've seen about a dozen criminals
to look out for in the game I'll link a
video breaking down nine of them and
their origins - I think it's worth a
watch to understand why they are like
they are why they do what they do they
include electro vulture rhino
Black Cats taskmaster kingpin scorpion
mr. negative and there's another one and
I can't remember and the shocker there
we go but since then we've all seen
silver sable and the moment Peter says
this in the e3 trailer we all think he's
talking about dr. Octavius but we can't
be certain until Sony confirms things
for all of us to fight these criminals
we need powers which are housed in our
Spidey suit again I have yet another
video breaking down seven confirmed
spider-man suits and their origins in
the upcoming game so I won't cover old
ground here but I will say that each
suit has a special characteristic which
can be transferred between any suits you
have unlocked for example the noir suit
prevent enemies from calling in backup
playing into a more stealthy playthrough
whereas the spider armor mark 2 which
has just revealed has the ability to
become bulletproof of course the
original suit is here too with a cool
ripped version like in the amazing
spider-man game or the movie version of
spider-man 3 so far we've seen 25 suit
slots in the game but I'm hopeful
there's a few more to uncover so how the
heck do we upgrade and unlock our suits
well simples everything is unlocked by
playing the game through the story and
open-world Peter will use collectibles
to craft suits should he be at a high
enough level there is a way to skip this
process with three of the suits the
velocity suit the iron spider and the
spider punk outfit can all be unlocked
from day one by pre-ordering the game
but don't worry if you don't want to do
that you can grind it out and earn them
for yourself at present we know off 23
suit mods to uncover these can be used
to customize your loadouts using three
slots to do this tokens must be earned
during missions but there are different
types one of the tokens we've seen our
crime token which are earned by our
listening into police scanners and
taking down perps who are currently
committing crimes and it's been
confirmed that those types of crimes
will escalate
as a story unfolds maybe this could be a
way to bring in Herman guess we're stuck
in here for a while
want to play 20 questions other tokens
include research tokens which are
unlocked by completing puzzles for Harry
Osborn based tokens are for defeating
swarms of enemies and there's also
landmark tokens which I'll talk about
very soon Oh on this maja backpack
tokens are awarded for finding the
world's collectables these come in the
shape of Peter Parker's backpacks which
he stuck to walls before going to fight
crime after a few years of forgetting
where the heck they are it's time to
locate them all these backpacks are
filled with Easter eggs our nod to
spider-man's past hidden inside you're
definitely going to want to find them
all but let's leave that for another
time and there's one more token type a
challenge token which is earned for
completing challenges in the open world
like many events such as defusing a bomb
left there by the taskmaster on top of
this customization is a skill tree with
three distinct areas of interest
webslinger innovator and defender the
defender is designed to improve combat
whereas the webslinger is here to
improve traversal and movement and my
personal favorites the innovative class
which is all about using gadgets the
gadgets range from the regular web
shooters which can be upgraded to shoot
more bolts or recharge quicker another
gadget replaces those shooters with
impact webbing which has the force of
five regular shooter webs if that's not
your thing then what about the spider
drone which seeks out enemies and helps
you out in battle next we have a tripped
mine which could be used to prevent
enemies from flanking you when used the
tripmine completely incapacitate any
Me's allowing you to concentrate on the
ones right in front of you other gadgets
include a concussive blast which is like
a sonic pulse to cause the enemy to fly
in multiple directions they're the only
ones I've seen so far but there are sure
to be many many more
have you played one of Rocksteady's
Pakman games I'm pretty sure you have
and if yes you'll already know the basis
of Spidey's combats and the fundamentals
under your belt but what you may not
realize is the plethora of additional
skills peter has to offer the gadgets
we've looked at are awesome but the
environmental interactions are second to
none ripping a car door off before
slapping it down on criminals head is so
damn satisfying the environment is your
playground with tons of unique attacks
available and if you can't see anything
to use right away then go back to your
web shooters and mix up straight
punching people in the face with a bit
of Peter Parker sorry
terrible joke the experimentation in
combat keeps the game from feeling stale
every fight is different if you choose
it to be and he'll be tested as new
enemies join the battle which have
different strengths and weaknesses
fighting a foal with the shield requires
a different tactic to one wielding a
light machine gun this is getting a
little too technical so let's scale it
back a bit spider-man on ps4 offers a
truly open world
I'm sure you've encountered many games
which lock areas of the world away until
your character is skilled enough to
unlock them marvel spider-man will have
the entirety of New York available to
you
as soon as the first mission concludes
the city is broken into eight districts
with the wrong theme and distinct enemy
types and gangs to fight but more
importantly let the sightseeing commence
segue remember earlier when I was
talking about tokens well these can be
collected inside missions and quests my
favorite is taking photos of iconic
venues around New York such as Madison
Square Garden Fisk Tower and maybe you
daredevil fans can locate Nelson and
Murdock Attorneys at Law of course the
first place we're all going to locate is
Avengers tower am i right or maybe
you're the kind of person who goes to
the games highest point to take in the
vista and plummet to almost certain
death whatever floats your boat
the world is your oyster marvel
spiderman comes to ps4 on September the
7th worldwide it'll eat up 45 gig of
space on your hard drive and future DLC
is already in the works the first will
be centered around black cat and her
relationship with Peter this game is
looking or inspiring and now within
touching distance I'll be playing the
game here on the channel so if you don't
own a ps4
let's experience it together I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]